- Your Google Play listing
is a vital part
of your app marketing.
Ensuring your listing
is the best it can possibly be
will improve your app's
discovery in the Play store
and convert more visits
into installs.
Here are ten tips for creating
a great listing.
Create a unique,
eye-catching icon.
A high quality icon created by
a graphic designer
will make your app stand out
in Play store search results.
Don't be too abstract.
Reflect the purpose
and character
of your app or game.
And remember, clean and simple
often has the most impact.
Add device screenshots.
Users want to know what your app
will look like on their device.
So include multiple screenshots
for every form-factor
your app runs on,
including all tablets,
wear, and TV.
And include both landscape
and portrait views
for smartphones and tablets.
Add a feature graphic.
Sum up your app or game
in one outstanding,
captivating image,
one that illustrates
your apps key features,
how it's used,
and what your users
will get from it.
A great hero image will
entice users to install.
Run experiments
on your graphics and text.
Our store listing
experiments feature
lets you test
different graphics and text
to find out which options
perform the best.
By testing different
high-quality app icons,
some developers have seen
double digit improvements
in their store listing
conversion rates.
This data-driven approach
let's you figure out
what converts the most users
so you can drive more installs.
Add a video.
A video will help visitors
to your Play store listing
decide whether
to download your app.
Your video should show off
the key features
of your app or game
and explain how your app
benefits users.
Show the app
actually being used.
If your app
is complex or unusual,
think about a how-to guide
or tutorial video.
Write a compelling
app description.
Sum up your app benefit
in your short description
and keep your long description
concise.
Long descriptions
might not even be read
the whole way through.
Make the first sentence count.
Grab the user by telling them
why they should install
your app or game
and keep the rest simple:
what your app does
and why it is valuable.
Choose your words carefully.
A clear and accurate description
of your app
will place your app in the most
relevant user searches.
A list of keywords
will be considered spam.
Make sure you review
and understand
the Google Play keyword policies
described in the policy center.
Localize your listing.
Add translated store listings
for all the languages
your app supports.
If you're requesting
a professional translation
of your app using
the app translation service,
you can add the text
for your store listing
to get it translated too.
And be sure to also localize
your graphics and videos.
Show off a little.
If you've won awards
and had great feedback,
let people know.
List the prizes.
Include examples
of your brilliant reviews.
Letting people know
how great your app is
will get them excited about it.
Respond to feedback.
Ratings and reviews
will improve your store listing.
Plus, replying to reviews
will show prospective users
you're a trustworthy developer,
while building loyalty
with current customers.
Follow these ten tips,
and you'll get a better
Play store listing
and more users clicking Install.
Head over to the Google Play
developer console
and spruce up
your app listing now.
If you want more tips on
how to improve your app
or games performance
and build a better app business,
check out the other videos
in this series
and download
"The Secrets to App Success
on Google Play."